asumiendo lo que yo he estado viendo
está en este momento de nuestra
democracia está bajo un asalto sin
precedentes a diferencia de todo lo que
hemos visto en tiempos modernos este es
un asalto
a la libertad al capitolio en sí mismos
un asalto a los representantes del
pueblo a la policía del capitolio que
además ahora ha jurado proteger a
democracia a los servidores públicos que
también trabajan en el corazón de
nuestra república un asalto sobre estado
de derecho como pocas veces hemos visto
un asalto en una de las labores más
sagradas estadounidenses deseos que se
encarga de sus tratos del pueblo déjenme
ser muy claro las escenas de caos en el
capitolio no reflejan a los
estadounidenses de verdad no representan
lo que somos
lo que estamos viendo es un reducido un
número de extremistas dedicados a
infringir la ley
esto no es disenso esto es desorden esto
es caos
las fronteras está en el borde de la
sedición y esto debe acabarse ya ahora
le pido a esta multitud que retroceda y
le permita a la democracia trabajar me
han escuchado decir esto en distintos
contextos las palabras de un presidente
importan
sin importar lo bueno o malo que sea ese
presidente
en el mejor momento las palabras de un
presidente pueden inspirar
en el peor
pueden incitar
y así
le pido al presidente trump
que vaya a la televisión nacional en una
transmisión nacional y cumpla su
juramento y defienda la constitución
y demande un final a este asedio
es un asedio al capitolio romper las
ventanas ocupar oficinas
el suelo del senado estadounidense
en la cámara de representantes-
amenazando la seguridad de los oficiales
elegidos esto no es una protesta es así
insurrección
el mundo está observando
como muchos otros estadounidenses
yo estoy genuinamente sorprendido y
entristecido
de ver a nuestra nación que ha sido un
faro de la democracia ver que haya
llegado a un punto tan oscuro
a través de la guerra y de las luchas
los estadounidenses ha soportado mucho
y seguiremos resistiendo y prevaleciendo
de nuevo prevaleceremos ahora el trabajo
de este momento el trabajo de los
siguientes cuatro años debe ser la
reinstauración de la democracia de la
decencia del honor del respeto
del estado de derecho es así de simple
la decencia
la renovación de la política trata de
resolver problemas de cuidar el uno al
otro no incendiar no aumentar las llamas
del caos y del odio lo he dicho eeuu
trata del honor decencia respeto
tolerancia eso es lo que somos eso es lo
que siempre hemos sido
la certificación del colegio electoral
de los votos del colegio electoral se
supone que es un ritual sagrado para
reafirmar los propósitos
la majestuosidad de la democracia
estadounidense
pero hoy recordamos
lo doloroso
y la fragilidad de la democracia lo
necesario que es preservarla
esto requiere gente de buena voluntad
líderes con el coraje suficiente para
defenderse de gente devota no a
perseguir el poder
o el interés personal
sino por el bien común
piensen en nuestros niños viendo
televisión piensen los que están
pensando lo que el resto del mundo está
viendo por cerca de dos siglos y medio
nosotros el pueblo
en búsqueda de una unión más pulida
hemos buscado el bien común eeuu es
mucho mejor de lo que hemos visto hoy
ver las escenas desde el capitolio
a medida que bueno recordando cómo
preparaba discursos del pasado recordé
palabras de abraham lincoln es un
mensaje anual que el yo del congreso
cuyo trabajo hoy ha sido interrumpido
por el caos aquí está lo que dijo
lincoln él dijo que debemos salvar
noblemente
[Música]
la última esperanza sobre la tierra
siguió diciendo que piso
se trata de hacer una justicia mundo
generoso justo un camino que si nosotros
seguimos el mundo aplaudirá
y dios mismo deberá bendecir por siempre
el camino que se está emprendiendo en
este momento esto es lo que somos es el
camino de la democracia del respeto de
la decencia del honor
y mi compromiso como patrio 30 naciones
no se trata de lo que hemos visto hoy yo
sigo siendo optimista de las grandes
oportunidades por las grandes
oportunidades que hay no ha habido nada
que no podamos hacer cuando lo hacemos
juntos
en esta horrible muestra de hoy
que ha llegado a la casa de cada
demócrata republicano o independiente
nación debemos dar un paso adelante
estos son los eeuu de américa
no ha habido nada nada nunca nada que
hayamos intentado hacer
que no hayamos podido lograr juntos
presidente trump por favor dé un paso
adelante
que dios bendiga a estados unidos y que
dios proteja a nuestras tropas y a todos
aquellos en el capitolio que están
intentando preservar el orden gracias y
lamento haberlos mantenido esperando